Blake is in Fayetteville North Carolina
welcome today Ramsey show Blake better
than I deserve man what's up in your
world question for you
so my for looking at trying to get out
of debt and we're trying to decide
whether we should get rid of one of our
cars or both of our cars okay how much
do on car number one all right car
number one we owe $17,000 and what is it
worth
and it's worth private so anywhere from
twenty to twenty six thousand okay and
car number two you owe what on car
number two we have thirteen thousand
eight hundred on and it's worth anywhere
from around fifteen around fifteen yeah
your ups your right side up on both of
them that's good news okay and what's
your household income
I make sixty six thousand dollars a year
mm-hmm okay well your car values total
more than half your annual income and
your your debt does not but we go by
value I don't want more than half your
annual income tied up and things that
are going down in value
what's the trajectory on your income if
you're making 66 this year what do you
think you're going to make next year
probably about 1772 somewhere around
there and then that gets us there right
because that's okay you got 37,000 and
values today so you're right on the
bubble you've got you've got the max
possible invested in things that are
going down in value never do this again
even if you keep this even if you keep
these okay because I mean let's say
you're making a hundred and you got
fifty tied up in cars as long as you
perpetuate this those cars go down that
you know they lose about sixty percent
of their value in five years four years
right in there and so you know you
really do lose your butt on them and you
can't I mean I don't might have a nice
car but I want to be a small percentage
of my income or smaller percentage than
you have how much other debt do you guys
have we have a mortgage which we owe two
hundred and thirty four thousand dollars
that's it yes so you're only debt other
than your house
your cars yes sir no student loans no
credit cards no medical bills loans no
credit cards their medical bill okay do
you like these cars
um probably the one that we are the most
on we're probably looking at getting rid
rid of okay and then we've gone back and
forth so there's things obviously what
is it what's the $22,000 car 2015 Honda
Odyssey okay
nice car very nice car okay well here's
the thing here's what I would do number
one don't let the purchase of vehicles
even with cash things with motors and
wheels total of all things you own with
motors and wheels ever approached half
your income again after this because
it's going to cause you to struggle to
build wealth you understand the concept
right yeah okay but so if you choose to
keep these that's fine can you pay them
both off in two years $31,000 in two
years the answer is yes that's 15,000 a
year if you can't pay out $15,000 a year
making 60 70 grand something's wrong
with you so set it on a two-year
schedule and you know that's like 1,500
bucks a month I mean you know you can do
this and you'll be debt-free in two
years or less you got to be do it
quicker than two years really but if
you're going to keep them get them paid
off in under two years preferably 18
months and never let the purchase of
vehicles even with cash approached half
your annual income again if you want to
keep them then you hit the guidelines
but you hit them barely and the fact
that your income trajectory is shooting
up to that gives us a little bit of
leeway here but it doesn't say we want
to repeat this or cause this to be a
pattern but if the pattern breaks here
and this is the last time and then
you're going to drive these cars out a
while and you're going to pay cash for
whatever you do from this point forward
and be a little bit more conservative in
your purchases in the future then you'll
be right on track is that logical to you
yes sir okay so if you want to keep on
my would but under those circumstances